Вітаю усіх. І Павло Володимирович.
взаємодіяти з вашим сайтом. Загалом, така практика досить корисна і навіть якщо ви не плануєте поки користувачів, тощо.
до бази даних, вас загалом, ще був працюючий приклад того, як це буде можливим. Тому в кого буде можливість продемонструвати екран і також відкрити потім пішов код прошу під'єднатися.
Давайте в Я спробую продемонструвати і виконати таку роль. Треба ж як це називається перемкнутися на роль студента із замовника будь ласка, Я виконую дії із демонстрацією.
Екрану.
Павло Володимирович. Керуйте що ж там губити?
Так спершу вам потрібно буде Зараз я відправилю посилання на сайт монку, дітей, і ви на нього знайдете і ми спробуємо зареєструватися осінньо-слав посилання.
Чудово. Загалом, тут ми можемо почати натиснутися на зелена кнопку така Катета: яка нас Загалом, має відправити на сторінку, реєстрації.
Чудово. Тут можна виконати 2. Способи. Перший Якщо у вас немає куку акаунту то власноруч.
Це всі дані про те, як у вас віко-каунт ви можете просто натиснути на Фейсбуку.
І загалом. Це буде простіший та швидше варіант так як є закон всі відповідні дані.
Так тут треба погодити що з їхньою політикою та терміном використання сервісу досить класний.
Чи того, нам, вказують що все вдалося. Тепер вони мають перекнути нас на сторінку все ж таки наша так тут є такий в них так звана персоналізація так до неї.
розробки далі у нас вони говорять хочу дізнатись краще про ваш проєкт і яку мову, ви використовуєте в нашому випадку, це джаз Скрик.
модель. Я вже зазнача основному занятті що у нас може бути мікросервісом архітектур ми будемо використовувати ось тут тому що в них є багато різних можливостей.
Тому ми будемо поки що нестоту що можна натиснути фініш.
Чудово І бачимо що нам одразу пропонують тут створити наш клас звісно, вони обирають одразу платний кластер тому нам треба обрати Останній який фрі безкоштовний після того, як обрали можемо йому дати ім'я фактично ім'я тут не є важливим.
Можна наголосити ось тут провайдер. Також ми лишаємо як немає. Різниці. Звідки він буде чи то з Амазон, так?
І так само, регіон також лишається це найближчі до нас експерт можемо натиснути клієнт.
У Так бачите, що от, нас тепер нам говорять загалом, що ви можете підключитися до цього клас автоматично пропонують ось такого користувача Але ви бачите перший пункт Додайте вашу епі адресу, що ваша епіадреса була додана тобто занести автоматично роблять додають нашу є
альпі-адреса яка в нас є на даний момент до дозволених мережі і другий пункт нам зазначають що треба створити користувача бази даних одразу пропонують по імені та пароль можете скопіювати можете створити крейт дати сьюз.
А чудово ось нам вказують що так дані треба зберегти обов'язково так як пароль він є лише одноразово тобто фактично ви його побачите 1 раз і отримати повторно ви його не зможете тобто вам потрібно буде перереєструвати користувача далі можемо натиснути вибрати метод підключення.
Так нам тут ось говорять: різні нам треба натиснути ось трайери.
Так Ми хочемо за допомогою драгоера підключитись і нам пропонують найпростіший випадок, який ми будемо використовувати що йдеться для нас це ночей і вона говорить ми можемо брати якщо ви будете Звісно, використовувати щось інше.
Ви можете натиснути на драйвер і там можна вибрати різні буде і той педагог, чи то для пайтону чи то для якогось іншого Другий пункт хтось нам говорить що вам треба відкрити командний рядок, у вашому проєкті і ось вести таку команду в лондобі, у вас є встановлений ночей.
Ну що в мене є? Відповідно? Ноч, Ес: який використовувався колись не у такому собі експериментальному режимі.
Не ось власне, він встановлений. У певному каталозі. І його я можу використати наприклад, просто Ось, у такому режимі.
Народ Ну, і звісно, я можу виконати команду Емпієм, для того, щоб необхідні дії.
Давайте спробуємо це зробити я у виконую вставляю її хвильку. Ще раз о цього разу вже скопіював відтепер вставляю і спробую її виконати не Власне, я отримаю помилки.
Коротко копіюєте команду?
Так. Це тому, що наприклад, ми минулих заняттях намагалися ініціалізувати новий проєкт.
проєкт я надсилаю посилання також то й минулого разу, було зада та вишне за допомогою якого ми і будемо слідувати всім кроком, які тут є зазначені Тобто це офіційна документація і ми і потім використовуємо тому що це найкращий спосіб навчитись нової технології.
Так. Ось ми відкрили сайт і зараз тут говорять що нам треба, щоб у нас був встановлений ну час наскільки я бачив Сергій Олексійович чи була версія 20 і ось нам говорять, що експрес-5 трапилось там потребує 18: Версій щонайменше у нас 18 Версій
щонайменше є тому Чудово, говорять, що ви можете створити робочу директорію.
Але у нас я думаю, що у Сергій Олексійович я бачу там є вже якийсь якась Папка.
Для роботи. Чи вам потрібно створити нову?
Так хвилько в мене я випробовую проблеми з продуктивністю перепрошую так значить, моєю метою є створювати зараз відповідний файл або щось новеньке на ваш розсуд.
Загалом, можете вам потрібна якась робоча директора. Де ми будемо зберігати наш проект, це можна створити окрему баку десь у вашій системі і використовувати відповідно.
Давайте спробуємо у каталозі який вже призначений для конкретної групи Нехай в нас буде якийсь проєкт під назвою проєкт.
Ось ми його. Спробуємо створити.
І тепер ми намагаємося відкрити саме ге цей каталог так.
Так? Це допомагає. Він жовтодюк.
21 він відкритий ми обираємо що ми зберігаємо конфігурацію у відповідному файлі і нам пропонується це зробити в якомусь там ну давайте нехай буде ось тут у цьому проекті.
Створено і збережено.
А чудово, тепер перш ніж ми будемо повертатися нам треба відкрити команда ряду, для цього ви можете натиснути Так, зверху ось у вас є 3 крапки, в лівому і тут є ось терметнав і новий торкнув.
Натискайте і ось у вас знизу відкриваються ось такі а якщо вона він знову ж таки це означає у вас буде трошки інший інтерпрес проте якщо ви аналіну всі то у вас буде використано.
Паш чудово. Тепер давайте повертатися до.
Сайт який надіслав ось такий ось нас всі цінилочки і ось нам говорять використовуйте команду, nп'є ін для того, щоб ініціативи ваш додаток і копіюємо.
До знак долару треба прибрати на початку та Ось нам пишуть що немає команди у випадку якщо використовуйте ліну то вам її треба встановити буде Але я думаю, що встановлення спрацює.
Тому що вам треба буде додати його в індус хоча б є змінні середовище не можу вказати як точно на лінксів казати на зміні середовища про те або ж ми можемо вказати повний абсолютний шлях, до емпієму.
команду Мм необхідно без казання повного шляху тощо.
Давайте виконаємо.
Така ж сама система буде Якщо ви працюєте під управлінням макес система управління пакетами.
Буде дуже схожі ви отримаєте, посилання що певна команда має бути виконана для встановлення на мм.
Чекаємо доки залежності не будуть задоволені.
Повертаємося ще до цієї команди, виконання якої не вдалося виконуємо цього разу без відповідного повного шляху ми можемо щось отримати давайте подивимося, так.
Так. Нам ось тут вказують що це літака, яка вам допоможе створити ваш пек основу, для проєкту ось тут можна вказати ім'я пакету або нашого проєкту якщо не хочете змінювати і воно лишиться проєкт та що в уста А версія також нам не важливо ми можемо використовувати цілком 1 крапка,
0 Крапон тобто також натискаємо Ентер і так ми можемо зробити для всіх опцій, які ми не вважаємо, що вони нам поки що потрібні опис ми також можемо пропустити цілком тут точка входу вказується це там, де аж буде основний файл ми можемо лишити як індекс єс так як ми будемо далі.
репозиторій. Дід але поки що він не треба тому ми це ігноруємо також натискаємо ентор тут ключові слова це у випадку, якщо ви хочете зробити свою бібліотеку нам це не потрібно тому ми також це пропускаємо натискає тут можна вказати автора, Проте знову ж таки, можна пропустити.
Тут нам пропонують ліцензії дало вони можуть бути різними. Проте якщо ми Поки що розробляємо локально нам не потрібна ліцензія на розповсюдження.
Ми також обираємо те, що йде пасажи якось нам пропонують Ось такий Ось у вас буде пеки, джийсон згенеровано Бачите, з усіма опціями, які ми вказали влаштовує та ми можемо натиснути енер.
І бачите в нас створилося в робочій директорії ось такий файл.
Кому.
О тут тепер трошки треба почекати, поки встановляться 3 дні залежності бачите, нам говорять, що додано 66 пакетів як ви можете бачити, також у нас додавці важливий файл це нот-моль на мочу.
треба ось помістити в індекс. Що Давайте спробуємо, це зробити.
Наразі Я не бачу можливості вибору відповідних файлів у форматі Джамаскріп.
І таке інше. Але я гадаю, що власне коли ми просто будемо не ім'я індекс джис то ми отримаємо відповідну можливість, Отже, не створюється відповідний файл, звичайний текстовий файл, до якого ми якраз і на намагаємося додати скопійований код, і зберегти.
встановити чи Єс? Також Так.
Угу А от і ні. Ми маємо Наразі помилку. Що в нас такий модуль.
Так помилка. Тому що в нас бачите, вказувалось за допомогою цієї команди аптеч у нас такого файлу немає так як ми використовуємо lem- індекс щез тому просто звільнимо трохи команду.
Файл. Не потрібно просто змінимо перейменуємо Файли якийсь тут навчається до Індексу крапка.
Чи єс? Він виконано?
Або або перейменувати і змінити у налаштуванні. Ось тут.
У альтернативний спосіб почув Хочете, так ось в нас є якась проблема. Бачимо.
Дуже дивна проблема говорить про те, що в нас немає відповідного рівня Модулі Експрес Чи Ase добре можемо переглянути можете повернутися до пекеч Джейсо Ось цього файлу який зараз відкритий.
Так, у нас є Департамент в залежності Експрес-джерсу вони є тому тут виникає питання.
Звісно, в чому у нас таке проблема?
Класичний варіант виникнення такої проблеми. Це встановлення конкуруючих версіях програмного забезпечення от ви бачили що в мене Ось тут була встановлена якась версія 20 І таке інше.
Давайте спробуємо його встановити схожим щитом.
З цією метою Давайте Ми спробуємо звернутися до відповідного офіційного сайту. Отже, ось він наша мета виконати встановлення під управлінням конкретної операційної системи що мені пропонується через те, що було визначено що в мене якась версія лінкс тощо.
Мені одразу. Ж пропонується завантажити ноджі Slet власне це завантаження і було виконано Але головне питання, яке стосується Що стосується налаштувань давайте спробуємо зробити?
Отже, я намагаюсь завантажити зараз воно йде це архів подібний до того, ви бачили я тут був для двадцятої версії а ми наразі завантажуємо якусь 20 другу.
І після того, як виконається завантаження нам потрібно буде виконати дійсно встановлення як не операційної системи.
Ми можемо пошукати що нам необхідно джез встановлення і Наприклад, як в мене відповідно є у бунту.
І ми бачимо купу різних варіантів, які стосуються того, яким чином нам це можна зробити значить, є варіанти є варіанти завантаження попереднього те, що ми намагалися зробити так далі.
Використання за допомогою Ось одного менеджеру пакетів нвя і використання за допомогою інших менеджерів пакетів мпія він пенсіон у нас Здається, було встановлено так значить що ми маємо зробити ми маємо спробувати виконати оці дії.
Дивимося успішно. Отримана наступним нам є налаштування відповідних шляхів. Виконуємо цю дію Звісно, я міг би узяти і скопіювати все це цілком але ж, як є далі.
Ми виконуємо встановлення єс з використанням Нвє 22 версії ось Тепер завантажується той самий архів але ще виконуйте додаткові налаштування налаштування шляхів є наступне ми маємо перевірити версія і має бути надрукований там 22 15 дивимося нот працює ну от Каренд має бути те ж
і ми маємо виконати індекс крапка, подивимося, нібито все гаразд, нібито все мало бути гар але все одно отримаємо проблема що ми маємо.
Можливо, Спробуйте бити цей термінал. Та відкрити новий.
Так, не до як то кажуть, недооформлення Давайте прибираємо це Термінал зараз ще раз.
Спробуємо виконати щоб нас оновилось усе середовище і таке інше. Так дивимося 22 15: 0 як треба індекс.
встановлено ноутбук Що ж, ми Наразі маємо прослуховувати щось на порті за замовленням 3 000 і Давайте я запишу інший вибух глядач для того, щоб спробувати це зробити мені пропонується звернутися за локальною адресою Локал холст саме за цим портом спробую це виконати Ось він Локал
Холст і відповідно через двокрапку не вказуємо номер порту 3 000 тепер ми бачимо, що в нас є працездатним відповідний базовий код значить ми можемо повернутися і працювати далі Дякую.
Павло Володимирович.
Так, чи то нас вже готовий ось такий приклад і Тепер ми все ж таки, можемо повернутися до підключення нашої панаси там тоді повертаємось до відповідної документації, Ванґедібі.
Ось і нам ось говорять: тут. Ми ще не виконали другий крок Нам треба бачите виконати мпієнс став манпедією.
Встановлюємо так само, як з експрес S це Ось можна вбити за допомогою контрал Сі.
Чудово і Тепер встановлюємо відповідно бібліотеку.
Чудово Ми додали е тепер можемо повертатися Загалом, до нашого до нашої документації. Ось нам говорять далі.
Тотайте відповідний рядок, Тут можна пнути. Ось такий відповідний слайд сам був поряд з Шоу-паспорт на третьому кроці, Так, олексій нам тут пропонують цілий приклад того, як загалом використати і перевірити чи взагалі підключається скарг до відповідного клієнта.
Банкутіки можемо скопіювати весь цей приклад і просто додати його до до індекс ще.
А чудово, зберігайте і давайте спробуємо його все ж таки, переглянути чи буде він працювати.
виконати.
стосовно про робу нами оті.
Думаю, що питань. Немає тоді можемо перейти до основної частини, яка сьогодні запланована це власне, таки розробку за допомогою ренту Дякую.
Сергій Олексійович за демонстрацію тоді можемо переключати з до основної Частини.
Добре перш ніж ми Загалом, перейдемо туди нам треба розглянути. 1 важливий момент, який в нас все ж таки є.
Так. Я зараз вмикаю демонстрацію. Екрану Чудово. Так, зроблю трошки більшим.
Так. Добре. Видно?
Ее загоном і ви бачите ось наш додаток розроблений минулого разу проте в нас тут є деякі проблеми якщо ми хочемо завантажити це токіт-хапри позиторі навіть якщо він буде в нас публічним, чи приватним у нас є те, яка невеличка проблема, А власне ось це А як ви пам'ятаєте, будь-що.
Так. Дякуємо.
Що ми закидаємо, на від хап у вигляді каміту у нас Загалом, туди завантажено, проте Проблема в тому, що ми не хочемо публічної репозиторії завантажувати та як підмітатись до нашої баз даних тому, що ось це повноцінний доступ до вашої бази даних.
Пакет? Який ми Сьогодні спробуємо використати Давайте його додамо Загалом, нам потрібен термінал, Давайте це в п'ю і відкрию новий а відповідна бібліотека.
Називається тот але нам допоможе встановити змінні середовища, загалом ви могли чути тому що він є і він став лінкс вони загалом для того, щоб визначати користувацькі дані атек у відкритому вигляді використати команду емпієнт Стол і вона називається ось тут-тот Н.
Так ось в мене проблема. Така якщо я використовую Павершел відкрию зараз Конопмб і Давайте спробуємо ще раз.
зміню імпортуємо відповідний пакет і нам потрібно вказати його ім'я так буде тот М.
Чудово і далі нам треба все ввімкнути конфігурацію тобто щоб цей пакет почав працювати одразу ж після цього рядку ми використовуємо сторон на незмінну до от м і натискаємось до Сонця, конфік тобто сконцентрувати.
Чи то бачите, у нас тут є звісно, говорять що можна вказати якісь шляхи але нас поки це не цікавить але що нас цікавиться в описі фолкції нам завантажує крапка Ен-отфайл його контент в ось такий об'єкт Просус: Ер.
За замовчуванням. А Чудово. Тобто ми можемо взяти зараз і цілком нормально. Працювати зберігаємося і як нам говорили, ми хочемо створити файл для наших змінних середовищ, це буде крапка.
N просто створили і ось ось такий простий пагорби працюють за дуже простим принципом.
Ж таки спочатку ми вказано тип зміни Так, участь. Не зміни аназу зміни а далі.
спробуємо. Тепер Га-га-га запустити наш відповідний додаток, і ми маємо побачити 1 2 3.
Вимети чудово! Тобто у нас є ось 1 2, 3 взагалі навіщо це потрібно По-перше, в нас таких файлів.
компаніях У вас будуть Тестувальники, Тобто це люди, які будуть перевіряти чи правильно?
використовують користувачі Це зробимо для того, щоб ми в умовах, схожих до реальтату користувачі працюють могли тестувати наш додаток, тому що тестувати не завжди є добре якщо наприклад, щось тестуєте і обов'язково віталій чиїсь акаунти або ж дані це не є дуже добре.
набагато простіше. Друге. Це Нам власне, треба створити ось цю зміну і використовувати для підключень.
Таких. Як Я не хочу закидати, на Кітха.
Ключ підключення до манки кипіє Ми його Давайте скопіюємо з вами.
зберегти Чудово. Тепер нам Ось тут. Її. Треба схожим шляхом отримати.
Використовуємо про асистент і тут монту Тібі юра.
нас є цей файл. Як він працює для цього у мене він вже створений Проте Давайте я видалю це відповідний пайл і для чого нам потрібні взагалі так як я зазначу вони є лише для локальної розробки, ми їх не хочемо завантажувати на гітха для цього в інструментарій.
відповідні, файли, які ми хочемо завантажити тому що бачите, ось поки що коли в мене є нот, модулі, і коли я натисну на контроль версії, так ти знаєш, що бачите мені ось тут, говорить що в мене там.
Тисячу 679 змі Проте їх реально, немає тому що я не робив стільки, змін у нас говориш що модулі вони також хочуть потім завантажити на себе, проте ми цього не хочемо робити тому, що тоді в Підхабі буде повноцінний смітник, з купою різних файлів, і так, як ми не хочемо його випадково.
Додати по тому що це велика кількість змін ми хочемо ігнорувати таких, змін тому давайте вкажемо що нотлочуть ось як перший рядок, зберігаємо ми бачимо, що він тепер підсвічується ось таким сірим, і в нас Тепер в контролі версіями.
Всього 4 пайли Але все ж таки є оцей файл N Ми не хочемо мета тощо.
Давайте ігнорувати.
Зберігаємо. Чекаємо, поки китановиться бачите, Тепер у нас лише 2 файлі які загалом були змінені Чудово.
Тобто ті файли як бачите, тут було прибрано ось це ось тут в нас є було додано Н пакет чудово.
Тепер давайте їх все ж таки додамо це у мене при позиторі від ха київ ми можемо використовувати я тут там відповідні файли і покажу там щось.
Додобите Наприклад, натискаємо пам'ять ентуш.
І намагаємось надіслати.
Чудово виглядає як була надіслано давайте тепер перейдемо до цього, апозиторію.
Так треба перемкнути екран 3.
Зроблю трошки більше так очевидно, амбрансер зараз.
Па бачимо лише відповідне завдання. Ми зараз Дякуємо.
Те, як ми хочемо все ж таки, завантажувати, у кіткава є безкоштовна опція Йцес: яка дозволяє нам завантажувати статичні сайти, підстатичні сайти, також чи підпадають складніші Наприклад, через додатки Проте там є навантаження є трошки складніший не подавай поки що
розглядати тому що для них треба буде використовувати автоматичні функції.
Названі тітка перша поки що ми підемо, і спробуємо, налаштувати йс Повернемось до нас з тобою сюди, А тут, бачите, в нас з лівого боку в нас тут є піт кот- над мельшин причес ось значить, така простенький Функціонал говорить кіт Пейджер спори для того, щоб
завантажувати ваші персональні організаційні проєкти з кіт-пропозиторів фактично ніхто не забороняє їх використовувати і в робочих цілях для ваших проектів так Взагалі, для бочок.
Бачите зараз нам поговорити. Кіт-педжис танки. Де тут не працює.
буде ро тото, всі файли які в нас є.
Ми будемо використовувати натискаємо сей ін трошки чека бачимо що нас додалось трошки опцій, і нам, говорить секіт сорт чудово і тепер бачимо що наша наш сайт за допомогою піт-хауджіс він є зараз в процесі як ми це можемо переглянути так просто переходимо ось сюди в меню
Екшн і бачимо що у нас останній моєму випадку, це коїться з білтен-диплоєм, і бачимо що ось у нас ось такий ось автоматичний процес який створює нам сайт ми можемо переглянути і бачимо що Чудово.
У нас всі ці кроки, виконані а повертаємось до наших підхапаючись.
І бачимо що ваш Сайт зараз працює. Чудово давайте перевіримо, натискаємо візит сайт і бачимо що ось у нас є е а наш відповідний сайт, який ми розробляли минулого заняття.
користувачами, кіткап гай і тут типостань в даному випадку воно працює за замовчуванням.
Лише тому що ми маємо папку. Має файл, який названий індекс тобто якщо файл, назва індекс то він буде працювати цілком легко Проте, для нас, це не завжди може бути опцією, а давайте спробуємо все ж таки повернутися нашому.
Нежостудія коду та все ж таки, спробувати змінити його наприклад.
Так. То 1 момент.
Повертаючись до обіжного коду, Давайте тоді спробуємо його змінити взагалі глянути що в нас буде як воно у нас тут взагалі співпрацювати.
індекс то вони не будуть так, співпрацювати Тобто зараз якщо ми завантажимо на точно 3 зміни давайте їх додамо, і кажемо, що ти чемпіон.
Так. І Пуш.
А чудово У нас спрацювало. Давайте зараз повернемось до А що Кіт Хабу і тут переглянемо загалом що ж у нас таке тепер у новому сторінку бачимо, що у нас оновився назва файл і тепер ми бачимо що інтерес на головній сторінці.
Ви можете бачити, тепло й над завантаженнях нашу відповідно екшен який ми тільки що зробили натискаємо бачимо що він завершився вже кара.
теоретично на нема опрацювати і звісно ж воно не працює тому що сервер у нас немає бачите якщо ми навіть завантажили клієнтську частину ми можемо співпрацювати якщо у нас сервер працює локально, добре бачите у нас Тепер є завантаження з якимось простим шляхом.
Клієнтська частина проте тепер нам йде більш складна частина це власне, таке. Завантаження серверної частини як було зазначено гідхаб підтримує лише клієнтську частину тобто ви тут можете піти на налаштування і тут Так, наприклад, у нас є кіт ха-ха-ха.
Так і не вказують, що вони там, найкращі для фрейборків та космізації вашого процесу побудови кожен із них обрати і бачите, нам, тут пропонують різні типи що можна підхатися Проте такий спосіб для того, щоб завантажити на вночі.
Сервер На жаль, немає. Повернемо диплойфом. Бренч.
І координати для цього. Для того, щоб використовувати загалом дчс і завантажувати його нам потрібно використовувати рента як це було зазначено на лекційному занятті Ренер це фактична платформа, яка нам пропонує дуже багато річного Функціонал 8 8 так ми
можемо перейти у нас тут Бачите? Є різні плани.
Так, наприклад, лан хобі, є професійні організації, або інтерв'ю нам потрібно для хобі нам не потрібно занадто складне і нам говорять що для персональних проєктів, та маленьких якісь додатки звісно, якщо ми хочемо більш краще функціонал нам потрібно а функції за
19 доларів Проте, безкоштовна версія нам говорить про те, що є нам дуже швидке завантаження можна навіть імена створювати а і багато іншого.
використовуєте Ось цей ліміт передачі даних Ну, звісно, у нас тут є також безкоштовні малень не побутове та ми розглянемо трошки пізніше.
Загалом такий підхід є досить актуальним для використання Проте, в нього є декілька проблем, які ми загалом.
І побачимо спробуємо. Тоді натиснути ось тут стартоплоїн у мене ось автоматично вже під'єднався мій акаунт, який у мене є і от нам пропонують створити так проект організації такого проекту натискаємо так більшу трошки так буде краще.
Натискаємо Крейд йорсар строчок нам говорять Тут створити новий проєкт Давайте якісь там нут беки ось тут говорять вкажіть ім'я назву середовище все залучення новий продаж тобто це вже там де користувачі працюють нам не важливо давайте це поки що і натискаємо квіти
проджати.
флантенду блогів, і сайтів з контентом веб-сервери веб-сервіс тут це Динамічні веб-додатки Далі для повностакових додатків 5 серверів та мобільних пакетів тут це насправді все що нам треба звісно, якщо ви хочете більше то тут є приватні сервіси коли створити
приватну мережу. Є спеціально-екран творкери які можуть робити синхронні задачі за вас є Ось тут заплановані задачі доступ навіть до воскрес реаляційної бази даних і Ось також є тут радіс.
База даних невеличких так яку можна також використовувати та зберігати як такого роду сховища про те, що цього всього, нам потрібно дати сервіс тому що нам говорять а й 5 з себе чудово ми натискаємо новий веб-сервіс.
І нам тут говорять шот треба вказати звідки братику ми можемо вказати що ми хочемо його прати з публічно відхапропозитори тому що в нашому випадку, він є публічним кожен може доєднатись до цього репертуару ми копіюємо його юра.
І тут вказуємо, щось колект чудово нам ось тут говорять назву вкажіть нашу вас у сервіси, Хай буде тест репозитори нам тут говорять до тексту проєкту Але у нас вже доданий нам ось автоматично знайшла мову як Бачите, тут є декілька варіантів д це може бути докар тобто якщо у вас вже
Мейн.
додати.
Далі важливий момент нам говорять для побудови команд і ось наводжу що орендар буде запускати цю команду кожного разу, коли ми там будуємо ваш додаток це загалом, працює по тому що ми хочемо подавати його кожен раз, коли новий нові зміни вносимо в наш репозиторій.
Приє ренд ну ось нам пропонують тут якусь ярму Проте, ми хочемо команду досить Просту.
локально. Ек Ми встановлювали інші всі залежності. Ось на сервер. Таким чином, встановити за допомогою команди імпічмент.
Нот Індекс крапка. Печес Добре і Ось нам пропонують тут декілька різних варіантів серверів як і випадки, з мамою дітей.
Нам хочуть пропонувати. Використовувати платні сервери, а проте ми не хочемо ми хочемо використовувати безкоштовно.
Як бачите, він тут, я досить лімітованим в ньому Всього 512 мегабайтів оперативної пам'яті і ось лише 0 крапка.
приходить з сервіс який пропонують відповідний функціонал, для того, щоб просто востаннє не витрачались.
Гроші, поки Ви не працюєте з себе. А Останній пункт бачите ось Нам говорять зміні, середовища.
Ось, тут власне, таки нам і треба вказати ті зміни, які ми вказували до то Давайте я просто скопіюю все що в мене було в тому файлі і вкажу письть обачте, тобто я там ось скопіював, став це все ось сюди, і воно.
Ось додало наш відповідний орел толто онкотiп тут Звісно, є ще додаткові функції чи хочемо, щоб автоматично воно завантажувалося про те, ми це не будемо поки що добре, у нас є вже 1 зміна середовища і ми дипломи все ми хочемо, вже його повністю завантажити.
Добре і чекаємо, ось поки він побудується так бачимо, ось говорять що безкоштовні десь близько п'ятдесяти секунд може бути в нас різниця між тим, коли ми зробимо запит і коли сервер відповість так ми тут говоримо що ми не маємо доступу.
До вашої аудиторії, Але ми все одно спробуємо його спланувати якщо це публічно репозитори то вам не треба навіть давати відповідний доступ чудово, ось бачимо що нас тут використовується Персонал через 22-14 ось в нас є банці і вже доли п'ємо.
статичні епіадреси які вже є повернемось до оман та дітей, і зайдемо в наше повільний акаунт.
Так дистанційно трошки зроблю більше нас.
Менеджмент бувко е наших Університету акаунт і до нього захоходив добре.
цих серверів. Тобто це може бути не лише 1 а будь-який тому що наш семи бути запущений на випадковому їхньому сервері м мережі, рент і ось тут бачите копіюємо адресу і нам тут, говориш що додавайте який адрес ми додаємо ми можемо встановити автоматичне видалення, Проте нам це не
потрібно.
Давайте натиснемо на.
Додати і космос він додається і тепер давайте все ж таки, додамо і інші адреси.
Схожий чи.
Оздуємо всі 3 адреси і поки все робиться давайте тоді перезавантажимо себе як його перезавантажувати досить легко, коротко.
Шановні колеги Перепрошую, Павла Володимировича Наразі технічні труднощі зараз він спробує не переприєднатися але принаймні та частина яка була необхідно ви змогли побачити Флянція опала.
Володимир ще перервалася на спробі перезавантаження серверу Будь ласка, спробуйте продовжити.
Вибачте він вирішив вимкнутися. У підходящий момент, і давайте зараз завантажити Так, давайте тоді повернемось до пластики нашої спроби перезавантажити відповідний сервер Так, очевидно, вам екран Ну.
Чудово для того, щоб перезавантажити сервер ми можемо натиснути принаймні у дипло і ось нам тут, натиснути теплом наприклад, лейтестками, тобто ми можемо з останнього боку.
Так. Видно.
Просто його перезавантажити давайте натиснемо перезавантаження.
А Так, щось наслідулось? Чекаймо Так, Давайте Ось Так, у нас є тоді щось сервер було перезавантажено ноги.
І давайте почекаємо.
Чим щось, нас працює.
Давайте спробуємо. Можливо, додати. З останнього крейту тому що щось ренерне перезавантажує відповідний сир, тому спробуємо просто фактично повністю з нуля.
Спробувати все завантажте тут Бачите? Кожен раз, у нас буде рекламувати і отримувати останній комісію в цьому немає.
Нічого. Ну, от такого. Але поки що спробуємо це зробити.
Так активу що в нас тут.
Так, бачимо що у нас все встановлено вже було тому що на цей серверс все ще за нами тому його ніхто не з добрав чудово.
Тоді чекаємо ось говорить що вже в процесі побудови.
Тоглом це займає близько Ну, пилинки часу.
Так запускається. Наша команда ми під'єднались до бази даних чудово, Ось зверху бачите, пропонують відповідний юрел.
тому в реальних умовах. Звісно, ж, такого не має відбуватися Проте бачите, що ми від серверу підтримали отримали відповідний.
Відповідну відповідь, чудово, тепер давайте все ж таки спробуємо це все під'їхати до нашої клінічної частини повертаючись до секунду я зараз увімкнув і жовтий япот тому що у мене вимкнувся ще минулого разу, і ми з вами спробуємо Власне, таке.
Зараз змінити деякі наші функції. А можемо змінити і всі функції. В нашому ось пайлі тест ми можемо ось тут Бачите, нас, до цього було колгосп 3 000 А ми хочемо змінити його до якогось ось нашого сайту і Давайте спробуємо це зробити для всіх.
Тобто і для панелі, входу, і для панелі, отримання користувачі зберігаємо бачимо, що в нас 1 зміна є додаємо її.
Можемо загалом.
Приблизно можна було б стати це цих джерел. До змінних середовищ але поки що нас влаштовує і такий варіант так Чудово. Ми його завантажили тепер можемо цілком повертатися до.
Нашого сайту і Бачите, що у нас відбувається так як це в нас був навіть відхабі.
Переходимо Кіт-хат і чекаємо поки в нас відповідна зміна відбудеться. Бачимо, що ось так у нас файлінг.
Тобто переходимо в екшн і тут бачимо, що у нас є побудова нашої відповідний сайт, Чудово.
отримали так само користувачів, які додавали з допомогою нашого серверу на ренер.
Загалом бачу що ми якраз по часу, встигли все, зробити в нас якраз 12 40 ага тому, я думаю, що можливо є якісь Питання незрозумілості стосовно бренду та й загалом процес якими тільки що намагалися робити.
Тепер власне кажучи гарна ідея буде подати посилання вже на розгорнутий на сторінках хіт-хаб до чату, щоб наші колеги змогли випробувати що це дійсно працює у тому числі поза межами цього заняття.
Так, зараз я надішлю. Тоді А.
Ірпаття, і випробувати ось той варіант, коли ніхто не звертається, що буде протягом 50 секунд, чи щось, яке доведеться очікувати.
Так, Я з надіслалась посилання в чат? Можете спробувати. Зайти додавати користувачів.
Хочеться, ім ми зможемо Загалом, з вами побачити, на екрані, хто там що по додавав.
Тобто це буде загалом досить гарним прикладом того, що Бачите, у нас працює функція для всіх користувачів, які є.
Можемо пробрати ось дуже складної частини. Я також можна надіслати вам відповідний код варіант.
Щоб ви наприклад, також могли побачити, що ви там можете отримати відпочне тільки я можу її отримати а й ви також.
О, Бачите? Всюди додав шаліку і в нас є новий користувач звісно, Добре, захистити це якось проте в даному варіанті будь-хто з заняття.
Може додавати користувачів, яких вам заманеться. Як бачите, цей користувач був доданий не мною а кимось іншим.
І він був завантажений до відповідної бази даних.
Так? Загалом можливо, тоді є все ж таки якісь питання? Щось вам було не зрозуміло, чи якісь моменти хотіли би побачити більше деталь.
Добре загалом тоді думаю, що під припиняю. Демонстрацію. Екрану.
Let your sisters renew.
Ось що тоді я думаю, вибачте ми саме 3 хвилинки трошки зайняли часу поза заняттям Проте можемо вирахувати те що у мене не працювало він був у той час того можна якраз зарахувати це заняття Добре. Тоді якщо немає питань всім Дякую за участь заняття і тоді до наступної п'ятниці.
Точніше до наступної середи ви дуже хочете побачити, не ось таку першу спробу воно вже має працювати попри ті обмеження, що є на 1 обліковий запис лише 1 проект електронної пошти, адрес електронної пошти, щоб отримати під всі ваші проєкти, безоплатне.
Ах Так. Достеменно.
Дякую. І До зустрічі на все добре.
Якого до побачення.
Дякую. До побачення.